[Cheering]
- I feel like the
pressure is just something
that you worked for.
Pressure is gonna come with you
being one of the top players,
with you being what you worked to be.
You can use it as fuel, or you
can use it as negative energy
and let it be our downfall.
I wonder how people would feel
if you asked LeBron about pressure.
He went to the league at 18 years old
and everybody was saying,
“He wasn't gonna be this.
He wasn't gonna be that.”
It's all on you. It's all mental, really.
- [Announcer 1:] Jabari Smith.
[Sports announcer chatter]
- [Announcer 2:] Smith, setup three...
[Squeak of tape rewinding]
[Sports announcer chatter)
- [Announcer 3:] He loves his three.
[Sneakers squeaking)
[Blues guitar music)
- 12:27 in the afternoon
when he was born.
Play that number Cash
4 frequently. [Laughing]
It was what every dad dream about.
Holding his own son, daughter, kid.
- Basketball really wasn't,
you know, forced upon me.
Like, I really loved basketball as a kid.
Like, I used to be watching the games,
playing 2K, like, anything.
Basketball was just me.
Just come from an athletic family,
so it was like, it was kind of natural.
- Well, this what you want
to do? You want to go hoop?
OK, let me show you
what's going on with this.
Like, OK, this is how you do this.
And he started—it’s an everyday thing.
Now “Dad, wake me up.” Five years old.
Like, before the bus come, put
the lights in the driveway,
turn the garage light
on. Now we got light.
- It kind of, like, felt naturally.
My brother playing it. My dad played it.
It's, like, it's just in my household.
So it's, like, it's hard
to say no to it, really.
[Video reel clicking)
- So I used to come home
from these overseas jobs.
You gone for five months,
so you ain't laying eyes on your kids.
And my last long stint was Iran.
The boy grew so much.
His brother grew so much.
So, you know, they picked
me up from the airport.
You know, I teared up.
- It was just hard for him to
keep leaving for many months
and then coming back
and seeing me growing up
and stuff like that.
He just didn't really
wanna miss out on that
too much more, so...
- I wanted to be a daddy
more than I wanted to go hoop
at that point.
- He could've played basketball
as long as he wanted to,
but he knew as I got older, he
just wanted to be in my life.
Cuz, you know, he grew up
without a father figure.
It was just his focal point
to just be in my life,
just give me that guidance,
just be there with me
along the way.
So, I just owe him to give it my all.
He stopped playing basketball for me,
so why wouldn’t I just go out there
and give it my all, maximize my potential
and just go as far as I want
to with basketball. So...
- [Interviewer:] Favorite
thing in the room?
- I got a lot of,
I got a lot of high school stuff,
but this is my McDonald's.
All of this has kind of
like made me kind of sad.
Cuz, you know, I ain't get to play
in none of that cuz of
COVID and stuff like that.
But this was the McDonald's
All-American thing.
This was the Jordan Brand Classic.
But they canceled them due
to COVID and stuff like that.
This was my Mr. Georgia Basketball plaque.
Atlanta Celtics jersey.
This is my USA jersey.
And this is from, um,
the Battle 4 Atlantis,
when we went into the Bahamas.
I got All-Tournament Team.
It's got some dust on it.
I really been adding
ever since I got here.
When I first got here, I
didn't have nothing in here.
Then I seen everybody
else's room, I'm like,
hold on, they can't outdo me.
- You know, Coach Dye, who is a legend
that we will never be able to replace here
at Auburn, told me, he said, you know,
and he's said it before,
you can coach them as
hard as you love them.
And so I don't love them right away,
cuz I don't know them right away.
But I get to know them,
I am honest with them and
I do hold them accountable.
If you had a dad in your life
or an uncle or a grandfather,
you put up with him because
you knew he loved you,
and he held you to account, didn't he?
And so I hold them to account.
- [Jabari Jr.:] Me, when I was
deciding to come to school,
I wanted to come somewhere
where I was gonna,
I knew I was gonna have fun,
and I knew I was gonna build relationships
that would last a lifetime.
And Auburn's just
really a family atmosphere.
- It's a small college town.
And so kids that come here understand
they're coming here to train.
They're coming here to learn.
- [Jabari Jr.:] To come here
just wanting to experience college,
you know, not going different routes.
Come to school and just play
for a national championship.
Play for a coach that's
coached people like me.
- He wanted to stay close to home.
He wanted his mom and dad to
be able to come see him play.
He wanted his dad to come
into the gym and train him,
you know, like he had
done, you know, growing up.
And I got no problem with
guys getting paid when
they're 18 years old, if
that's what they wanna do—
go to this league or
that league or whatever.
But, man, they're missing out
a lot by not going to college
and just having this experience.
And I'm telling you right
now, Jabari wouldn't trade
this year at Auburn for a lot of money.
He wouldn't trade it.
That money's down the road,
and he's getting ready for it.
- My junior year, I remember,
I just remember my Auburn visit
when they played Tennessee.
Sold-out crowd, it was loud,
how free the players were playing,
how much fun they was having,
how together they were.
It was just, like, why
wouldn't you wanna play here?
Why wouldn't you wanna
play in that environment?
Just time flies, really.
I still remember when I
was sitting right there,
over there, watching the, um,
watching the game thinking,
"Dang, I wanna, I wanna play in college.
I wanna play in the SEC. I
wanna play in a game like this."
Just me being in it now still feels
kind of unreal a little bit.
Seeing my name on the back of the jersey,
putting on the uniform every night,
it's just, it still
feel kinda fake to me.
[Sports announcer chatter]
[High-intensity motivating music]
- We're gonna make history.
This team's beating the
best teams in the country.
OK? We're gonna build our resume.
Kentucky and Alabama
and Gonzaga and Baylor
and whoever it is, is the
best team in the country?
All right, we gotta go through them!
We gotta go through them!
And they gotta go through us!
Let's go! Let's go!
[Clapping]
They gotta go through us!
- [Player:] Let's go, Auburn
on three. FLC! One, two, three!
- [All:] Auburn!
[Cheering]
[Laid-back hiphop music]
- [Announcer:] Jabari,
left wing three. Got it!
Night! Night!
- [Jabari Sr.:] Man, I want Jabari to
be one of the best guys
in the community.
You know, I want him to
change so many kids' lives.
I want him to be an impact,
preach being a father,
a family man, a husband.
I want that to continuously
come out of his mouth.
- If you tap into the
fact that we’re here
to educate young people and
get them ready for what's next,
that's what I want for Jabari.
I want to do the best job in this year
to try to prepare him
for what's coming next.
- That's the goal, you
know. Make my family proud,
make my dad proud.
You know, make it.
I feel like I'm on the
right track to do that.
[Calm piano music]